heads up guys my name is Jonah and
welcome to episode 24 of the Sparky game
mansion series in which we make a
beautiful game engine from scratch in
C++
so last time we had the amazing
experience of creating audio files
that's our own key I didn't what is up
guys my name
oh I should have so started the episode
off with that maybe I should rerecord it
I will remember to record all right are
we ready what is up guys my name and
welcome to episode 24 the beautiful
Sparkle game engine series and we make a
game engine from scratch in C++ so last
time is equally tell by my awesome intro
we did audio and we have the ability to
do a lot of cool stuff such as loop
audio and stop it and do whatever we
want with it which is pretty cool and
even increase the volume and whatnot
because here that's decreasing the
volume anyway best so we are with that
and the reason I'm so happy is because
we're basically done this is what I like
to call an informal code lock because
we're basically done in terms of adding
features all we're going to do now is
fix existing features now this episode
is all going to be about the in script
in preparation the M script in
preparation is going to be about
basically just it is this is almost
going to be like a maintenance episode
we haven't really had a real version of
those really haven't had a real Mensch
in this episode because we've done we
basically just had issues and bug fixes
but we haven't really thought about
minor stuff and this is what this
episode's going to be about because next
episode episode 25 we're actually going
to be compiling Sparky into JavaScript
using M scripting which is a big deal
it should go generally okay because I
have done it before but it there are
there are issues with this that will
prevent us from doing that the biggest
issue right now is guerrilla audio which
is what we did last time guerrilla audio
and I mentioned this several times is
only going to be used for only going to
be used for
Desktop okay Windows Mac Linux for the
web but we're going to use JavaScript
for all audio stuff and we might even
use some kind of JavaScript library I'm
not sure we'll probably just do it via
plain JavaScript there so that's fine we
don't have to worry about that
everything else though including free
image I've decided now has to be like
has to be compiled in JavaScript okay
why am scripting via M scripting so
because of that because M scripting is
going to have such a big job we need to
kind of clean this up and make sure that
it's generally flawless so to do that
we're going to spend this episode
basically just going over a few minor
things and fixing them up so the first
thing I want to do was last episode in
last episode I recorded like I finish
recording that like 15 minutes ago
I actually forgot to so we had this am
playing equals false in the pause but we
didn't set it back to true when we
resumed it and we had quit here for some
really weird reasons let's just fix that
up a little bit and I'll actually pop
this after after these are now I'll live
with that
just because in case that fails or
whatever doesn't do it again anyway
that will be fantastic so one thing we
should do is also if am playing return
because we don't want to resume if it's
already playing and same here if it
doesn't actually do anything I'm pretty
sure but yeah so if I'm playing return
so if we just test that out really
quickly because that was a minor thing
that I kind of took off for some reason
what is up guys money
okay that seems to work okay great so
that's done
um now one of the biggest things we had
was textures so we'll save that for last
but there are a few little things first
of all first first of all static friends
what on earth are they they're not
actually a thing obviously if it's like
a friend it's not static it can't be
static so let's get rid of that because
it's not even part of the glass so can't
be static if it's a friend let's get rid
of that okay
gone we that was just not correct at all
the other thing that's not correct in
terms of C++ was in my battery under I
had a sorry in renderer I had a Const
mat for you can't actually have Const
types inside vector okay that's not good
so we could we have to get rid of that
as well all right anyway those are very
minor things too that we just needed to
clean up because am scripting basically
clang would have would have which is a
different compiler would have complained
about that whereas the visual signals
lost compilers like enhance fun so
that's important okay that was easy
let's probably fix the texturing issue
oh there are a few different things that
I need to there was one more thing that
I wanted to do which was the tile layer
because that shouldn't be part of our
class this is going to be quick episode
by the way but the longest part of the
episode is gonna be now which is when we
have to fix this textures off so right
now we support a maximum of 32 textures
yeah what happens after that is you can
see flashes well it doesn't really like
clear it or anything it's not something
that we do we should do that it needs to
clear them every frame basically so what
we want to do is this we want to have a
hash define up here which is called
renderer max textures and we'll set that
equal to like a two right hours 32 we're
just going to set it lower what we set
it to us I mean just to test it in a
minute
I what we'll do is in RM texture slots
so we'll change this to be
renderer Mac's textures we do all this
stuff that's great so you can see it has
to end flush and begin now what happens
is when you flush it okay we need to go
clear on these so it clears all the text
without done how we could do that up
here but whatever we'll do it here okay
so now that's clear let's just want it
it should run exactly the same way so I
might say it's a little bit inefficient
to do that it's not really I mean I
think we were getting 5800 frames per
second before and release mode let's
just check it again
clearing a vector is quite fast well not
not the clearing part but like that is
fast but because it doesn't actually
clear it doesn't delete it obviously
yeah it's performance is the same in
fact it's actually performing better
when we play of sound though is it what
is it always know right that's good
actually I don't know why we're running
slightly before but whatever ah great so
now that we've done that we need to
probably drop that to something very
small and see if it still works so how
many we've got like let's just drop it
to two and see what happens
I think we're using three textures so
we'll see we have to make this work
there whoa look at that performance what
hmm what do you guys see that
wow we're doing something very wrong
let's go just verify that holy guacamole
so like six six and a half K I think
right or six K fps
and if we drop the max textures to two
we go down to
like 200 frames per second oh my
goodness so just to encourage like we
can probably find our HDTV ourselves but
I actually want to run this through the
profiler because I think it will be more
fun are not in release mode though out
Oh actually does the release mode did we
set release mode to have inlining any
suitable let's change that to disabled
you can go away
okay this is interesting I did not I
have to say I did not expect that
that is very low so yeah
so many draw calls we have actually but
that should be enough let's just see
that's where all performs are going
because we could be doing something
wrong that's seeming likely but the
other the other thing you have to
realize is that reducing this to two is
going to kill everything so it looks
like that is that so why is it okay okay
so we're yeah it looks like we're
actually fine looks like what's going on
is the majority of our time is actually
spend in open jail ninety-six percent
which tells me it's not nothing it's not
anything we're doing it's just the fact
that it's actually begin so this buffer
mat buffer is taking the most time yeah
so it's not something that we can
actually fix unfortunately because it's
just rendered this is take it submit is
taking the mouse let's go into submit
real quick you can see that nothing in
submit including our texture stuff is
actually taking them out it's just the
fact that you can see that since this
happens very frequently okay
it needs to flush what it's currently
got and begin again so what we could do
quickly just for curiosity is we could
give um let's just say yeah so we could
probably count the amount of draw calls
that actually goes into this so just to
do this in a kind of dirty dirty dirty
fashion I'll just make a static int DC
draw calls equals zero
we will every time we flash so every
time we draw elements we'll increment
our draw calls and then once per second
so this is going to be notice that's
going to be drop-off per second we want
roubles per frame so we'll set that back
to zero
and then before we update we will we'll
see how many draw calls we're getting
zero what a solid number
why zero
it's so weird wait is this hi I'm at
what
that's a bit weird what is being reset
somewhere that is weird
oh right no that's fine what okay let's
not go that way let's go that approach
let's pop it in here and that's a good
way it there
okay all right
93 draw calls okay ridiculous so 93 draw
calls per frame versus versus one which
you'll see if I go into renderer bash
renderer H and I said there's exactly
like 8 or whatever it was we'll set it
back to 32 because that is really do max
you can see we're dealing with 1 draw
pool okay and you can see that's why
it's much faster so that's an important
lesson on draw calls as well so we'll
change it back to 32 because that is
good we'll get rid of this draw pools
variable that was just for testing but
now you can see it does still work when
we when we go past the max textures now
as you can see our scene look do exactly
the same we fixed it so that it does
work all we had to do really was clear
but um it's it's good so that's the
important thing
we'll get rid of that and that okay
fantastic so we should be back up to
pretty fast speed okay one more place I
forgot to remove it all right great
so that's pretty much it I wanted to
remove tile layer we'll do that and then
this episode is basically done okay
that's it slow
should be six six and a half thousand
shouldn't pinch and it'd be maybe
because I'm streaming or something I
don't know a performance measuring is
bit dodgy okay let's before we I'm
scripting it let's also profile it
anything else I wanted to do do
something light as default shaders
should this be the default shader stop
our line we can make a default chatter
I'm oh I know why
Oh what what Oh gasps interesting but
okay I know why it was slow though
that's so weird
I know why it would slow those because
we disabled inlining and that gets rid
of like 2,000 frames per second as you
can tell
you
okay
so we should be back up to like six cash
yeah great so we're around 6,000 FPS as
you can see fantastic
and we run quite a lot of brides which
is nice um I'm pretty happy with this so
let's get rid of tile layer so one thing
I wanted to mention and I mentioned this
off recording but on stream is we've got
this tile layer this is not this is not
supposed to be part of the engine
clearly like it's a like this is pretty
much an empty class and it has a
projection matrix hard-coded into it
this isn't actually supposed to be part
of the engine this is an example of what
you would implement yourself okay so
what I mean by that is yeah this is
something that you would pretty much
implement yourself so outside so when
you're making a game you'd make a tile
layer you'd make like debug layer you
make a text layer a hard layer UI layer
whatever right that this is an example
of how you would do that so this is not
something that you should be doing here
though it's not something that should be
part of the engine so we're going to
delete it I don't actually want to
delete it though because it I want to
just copy it and put it outside so I'll
just I'll grab this I'll copy it and I
will pop it into Sparky core and into
like next to main because that's like
our example and then I'll come over here
and I will underlay as a tile layer I'll
just delete that and I'll delete the
files as well okay so now main is going
to complain main is the only thing that
you can play in right nothing else
should care and it something complaining
here so all we have to do is include
tile later edge like this
and let's refresh this tile out like
this including project again let's just
pop sound and we didn't have that
oh dear oh dear
okay so we're cleaning a few things up
as you can see all right great
string until should be in utils and tile
layer should just be here okay great so
what happened to sound I it is okay so a
few things are first of all this is not
my name space that we'll be using this
has been no name space because it's not
part of Sparky part of our test game
which will be in whatever names place
you want this has to include source
sorry doesn't have to go back source
graphics layers layer does it need the
batch renderer
oh yeah it does because creates it so we
should make headers which have all this
stuff as well source graphics patched
renderer so Sparky graphics layer you
should never use using namespace
obviously in headers by the way I hope
that's apparent
and then this will just extend that this
will just use this so you can see we've
now kind of taken this out of these
bulky stuff it's now just completely
part of our own kind of game and if we
run out you should run the same but now
it's no longer part of Sparky which is
good now certainly I like your great
layers it's what I mean based on like if
you want to use a different shader
you'll just create a new layer
that's husband to work right now I don't
know if I'll ever change that
actually because it like maybe when 3d
stuff comes along possibly but for the
most part you probably especially
intuitive you probably won't have too
many different shaders anyway so
fantastic that's done anything else so
what I wanted to do is create right now
yeah right now what you have to do is
okay let's get rid of this by the way
this is our um gorilla audio test files
get rid of that and I think there's some
like yeah like this stuff we are needing
at so we had font manager this is like a
testing so we had audio and then we had
so there's some graphics graphics
buffers graphics layers we had a lot of
different stuff here and just graphics
as well
static sprite we should probably get rid
of the simple renderer entirely to be
honest it's never going to be supported
yeah we will get rid of it say goodbye
to the simple renderer guys it's getting
deleted what else do we not need static
sprite so static sprite and and if you
want like it'll still be on github
version control but I'm getting rid of
it so yeah sorry
graphics static sprite remove and delete
it's gone renderer simple 2d renderer
move delete alright let's just build
this again make sure everything's still
good it should be no one no one misses
the no misses those those guys yeah yes
I was going to make a main loop kind of
thing elsewhere but I'm actually going
to save that for the improved apps that
I think is there anything else I wanted
to do
yeah default default shaders are a nice
idea but I don't think I'll do that
because it's just not really not
necessary yeah I think we're done this
is a quick episode but um I hope you
guys enjoyed the episode 24 of Sparky
next episode we're going to be compiling
all this stuff in terms Krypton and it
should be the best so hope you guys
enjoyed that and maybe I should make 24
and a half as well in episode because I
really did want to cover the main loop
kind of stuff let's do that right now
actually I've decided on the fly live
let's just do this now so under source
which is in the Sparky thing I'm
actually going to add a new item which
is going to be a header file called
Sparky
okay dot H so what happens is if you're
making a Sparky Sparky application you
want to where is was the file I just
created
that's a header file yes so if you're
making a if you're making a Sparky
application you basically include this
header file and overwrite things and
everything is the best so that's kind of
the way it's going to work
so ah pragma once namespace Sparky class
Sparky and you'll have some private
stuff it'll have some protected stuff
and then we'll fix up a prescription as
well to work with this don't worry so um
public so it'll have a constructor now
this will be a header only because you
only include it once anyway we should
have a so that's the public will have a
public constructor will have like void
really everything should probably be
protected let's do that
there shouldn't be anything that's
public I don't think in this void okay
so we'll have we'll have a few things
and I'll explain what they are
we'll have unit this is a virtual void
in it which is going to be so much this
is going to be pure virtual will have in
it will have will have four things will
have in it will have tick will have
update and you guys are going to be
compute confused because you feel like
what's difference being taken up there
and you'll find out and render now we
might have like some kind of shutdown
thing as well
in fact that'll probably just be the
destructor so we'll make a virtual
destructor I don't think the constructor
will probably do much it might log a few
things but I don't think it'll do too
much
make sure that's virtual okay so what
happens is this runs runs when oh and
we'll have to have a start as well so
this will run in it and run and I'll
explain all this stuff in a minute and
run will be private avoid run so there's
a lot of the main game loop so we also
need to create window don't we so will
window will be handled probably by this
class so include a graphics window so
we'll have a graphics window M window
maybe a pointer over here we will delete
em window so we'll have stuff here after
all we'll have a I guess we'll make it
will let people retrieve it they'll need
to because um a full input and whatnot
so graphics window create window or
create display I think window probably
sounds nicer so this will wrap whatever
this does so grab their stuff at host I
chose to do this this episode just
because then it was a bit it was a bit
short
so the other episode that is so okay so
M winter equals new graphics window name
width height return M window
okay runs once upon it so this runs once
per second so tech is going to run once
per second that's a useful thing to have
update is going to run sixty times per
second it doesn't really matter if you
render things in
I was going to say yeah it doesn't
really matter if you render things in
the update method or anything like that
since these are running on different
threads at the moment I don't I don't
know if they will in the future I
haven't decided that yet but um now
they're not so anyway this is looking
pretty good and we could even have stuff
like get FPS and all that cool stuff so
we'll make that stuff in a minute but I
just wanted to add a little bit of
documentation you have to implement all
of these clearly okay so what started
what you call to start this stuff up
okay um
good
okay run so let's just copy our game
loop when I'm going to exactly copy it
obviously but we will copy it a little
bit so what we have here so we've got a
bunch of we need to make a texture
manager that would be that would have
been nice but too late code lock well
this is kind of probably going against
that but anyway so while M
window dot closed so here's what we're
going to do this is basically going to
handle a lot of stuff for us so we had a
time our didn't we this stuff so this
was our once per second timer we had a
frame counter so we'll count frames
we'll just do that um we had we just had
a time it didn't we
we really want to start it when it
actually starts though so what we'll do
is this will make it a point it'll make
pretty much everything in this class a
pointer I think we'll start the timer
over here so when when you actually run
it which is what happens when you when
you run the start method so window dot
update and France plus plus all that
stuff happens in here we need so there's
our timer that's clearly that on one
think we just we called it time didn't
we
okay that's the only time we actually
used it and we had a timer as well
fine we'll call it time well actually
know what is call it M timer and we'll
have a different time that's make it
confusing a bit of whatever I was going
to go into the header file but I've
already notified because it's
implemented in the header file anyway um
so um M window dot update I'll point
some update okay cool
so get out get out yes
we need to have an unsigned in frames I
might actually just make a type def
called au end which is unsigned and I
haven't done like those farther so I'm
probably going forward doing that okay
so there we go
let's clear the window clear the window
we want to render in here and then we
want to update when we're 60 times per
second so right now we could may
probably make another timer that does
that like a flood delta kind of time so
right now we're doing that and that's
once per second so let's do this let's
make a just thinking the best way here's
what we could do I think I think we
might just make another
update timer this might actually be
better let's not set it equal to that
though let's set it to we set a time to
labs Jen we here now we didn't we set it
to zero
oh that's cuz it yeah okay that's
interesting so we'll set it equal to
zero fine doesn't matter and then we'll
say float on our update tick I I'm
creating names at this point we'll set
to that and we'll say if timer elapsed
at Santana well I did not work out M
time adult elapsed is greater oh sorry -
update timer so whatever in kind of
similar thing here is greater than
update tick tick yeah there's a few
dozen so many different ways but get it
done this but this is one of them my
refactor this in the future to be better
and then we'll do update
okay cool that looks pretty good so we
could have a protect it yeah so let's
have updates per second so we'll set
we'll set that and then we'll have
unprotected I guess why not Const int
Const unsigned and with those unsigned
ads which really initialize them to 0 as
well okay
get FPS that'll get updated once per
second clearly and then get ups updates
per second not the shipping company ups
okay I'm feeling pretty good about this
hopefully everything is the best um
sure seems like it
okay great so how would you use
something like this that's the next
question this is our kind of test game
right now how would we use something
like this so let's go into Maine and
let's just shut the whole thing off so
it doesn't actually get compiled we
could just remove it from our project
but I don't want to do that let's go
into Shore files here
let's make ups let's make a folder
called examples now let's add a new item
so called
game built epp so this is this is
officially and all of you should
probably listen up here because this is
officially how you write a game in
Sparky so beat news so what you want to
do is first of all let's include Sparky
dot H
which apparently is in the same folder
that's wrong I hope that's wrong it is
wrong good so you probably want to
actually add it into your include
directories but doesn't matter yeah we
don't want add it into the breath which
probably should have made this in a
different project actually doesn't
matter this is an example so Sparky -
then you probably want to make a game
class and a main method a main function
I should say so you extend or you
inherit from Sparky it's safe to say
using namespace Sparky in this case
because we're in our game does EBP so
you're doing that you probably want to
have a constructor and you can have this
as a header file if you like I'm just
running it here because I'm amazing
we'll have a destructor you would you
will want to have a destructor okay and
then we'll have a few private members
probably as well okay and then what we
do is we make a game and then we go game
door start well
visual sis I'll just got visual assisted
hope that didn't like destroy everything
because I seem to do a few things
dodgy yes so obviously we can't do this
yet because we have to overwrite
everything so avoid so I'll make it I'll
make I'll make this the case you you're
not going to get forced to override tick
which happens once per second or we're
not following that tick should happen
here and let's just lower this so it
happens after the method a subject
should have a noun so you're not going
to get forced to do this or update so
all you actually need is in it and
render and that's it those are the only
ones you're forced to actually do so
let's just do in it
oh my class override don't have to but
you can and render okay so start is
inaccessible or start needs to be public
su
what happened here goodness we did
something visual assessed did something
to us oh please please still build
roughly good thank you okay anyway on
the bright side it looks like this is
building so here's what we want to do so
we probably do want to store a window in
fact I'm just going to use pretty much
all the namespaces so window M window up
reviews
yeah use that so we'll set window equals
to equal to create window test game 960
540 will probably make a layer this is
good because it also I encourage you to
actually see what's going on so we don't
have to delete the window luckily that
gets done for us we do need to leave
stuff like layer though so layer okay so
this needs to include layer this needs
to include a lot of stuff so layer layer
includes a lot of stuff though so we'll
leave it as out now okay we need to make
some kind of layer class as well
probably we should make some kind of
simple layer thing as well that should
be a thing we'll figure out though
because I don't think you can is this
capable of doing things yes it just
needs to okay no that's good I'm happy I
did I did it that way
so include maths maths dot H okay so
we'll go layer equals new layer
we'll make sure whether we gets deleted
layer because in your layer
oh yes thank you Polymathic who just
reminded me in the stream that I need to
do this this is very important and
should be covered this episode this tax
IDs thing has to happen by probably the
shader or the de layer basically
so right so this setting of these
textures okay so I need to do that so
yes thank you
new layer what do we want here we want
to render up so we can just go a new
batch renderer to D again this is
something you'd handle yourself but new
batch render A to D which will have to
include here
what's the next thing a shader so new
shader our shaders get tired yeah later
so source shaders basic dot vert basic
defrag and I will steal our we deleted
it
maths Matt for project up it sorry
oh yeah was do orthographic
and left right bottom top -1 1 okay
whoo I bet yes that'll be including
everything Watts let's just compile as
quickly
I was projected now we won't make that a
thing we did make this thing but I've
decided against it because it could be
good for quick creation of things like
this if you just want to quickly make a
layout because it implements everything
anyway doesn't it I guess it does a pen
on the round over there
once quickly just verify no no it
doesn't okay great so yeah I've had tile
I was right Tyler I did nothing really
except except call the constructor
probably okay cool that's done okay clay
is done so let's have been a sprite
that's not a thing yet
new sprite so 0:04 for texture we can
just set a color and then over here
we'll just call layout render so that's
looking pretty good I think let's just
run that and see what happens
I doubt this will work but hey he'll
just let me knife type like four lines
of actual code oh no it will work so
it's still using our other shader which
is pretty funny and oh yeah so it's I
guess it's a little light too
I guess the uniform add a default light
or something I don't know anyway that
worked which is nice you can see our
test games here and everything totally
works which is nice
oh yes there's something very bad in the
font rendering that I just remove it
about so this is what this episode is
about clearly just all this scampering
this scaling that is terrible oh that's
so bad that's a quick way to fix that so
there should be like a set scale thing
performed probably yeah we'll do that
that's the easiest way it fix this so so
we'll have a scale and we'll have a void
set scale float X and float Y and let it
get scale
okay cool
and I'll quickly implement that you'll
okay so this isn't font right so maths
vector okay so now in our batch render
our will grab the font and scale X and
scale Y we used in plenty of places so
let's just say Const maths vector scale
equals font get scale and we'll make
that a reference
obviously we're going to copy them
compare values as scaled of X scale or X
scale Y scale that X scale - why
just gather X okay now we can go to this
okay so now it was yeah so it was
basically with / or whatever so we'll
say when we create the font so there is
the default font so if we can we just do
that for manager is there a font manager
there should be a get that just gets the
default one I've just thought of it I
want to add so many new features so this
should just return em font zero and that
should definitely be a thing because it
will be anyway um okay as me we don't
give other anymore when we pass on so
let's go ahead and say font manager get
set scale to M window dot get width
divided by 32 which is 32 by the way is
the range of a lie to that horizontal
range and we'll set the height let's
just call window my dad
- 18 okay right so that should still
work now we're not actually rendering
any false let's render the FBI sizzling
so it's I'm getting a bit carried away
I'm actually just making a game now
what's up with this already has a body
oh yes my bad so label label label FPS
okay
so we will set FPS equal to a new label
I think we've got a lot of options don't
we yeah we can just do that so we'll set
the X and y equal to like one fifteen
point five minus like eight color to
white and yeah so it'll just nice that
at FPS fps oh you know what we could do
see at this point we can override tic
and set FPS dot txt equal to get FPS
which i think is an unsigned for
whatever the version should totally work
let's just try this and see what happens
so the lighting is probably stopping
that I really should get rid of the
lighting like that should definitely
happen because clearly it's nice it
shouldn't be here like that was just a
cool kind of feature okay so I'm not
seeing my font okay yes I am it's not
going to happen off the per second but
this is a that's weird
what let's try that
there we go okay oh that position what's
wrong there
Oh what it is my bad
I meant to do that okay
sweet let's move that down a little bit
but yeah it looks looks pretty good so
you can see how easy it is to make a
game in Sparky that's it I mean it's not
really a game obviously but it pretty
much is
yeah so there you go
like add a texture pretty easily as well
we've got a test texture right if I
wanted a texture I just go a new texture
test or PNG and that should just work
exert it did what's another different
texture that I could try tbh del P Angie
for example no problem there you go Oh
problem that's actually my bad though
okay so that comes up to a snot setting
this stuff up so this should happen this
should happen by the layer so the layer
should do that the thing is it probably
doesn't want to yeah we'll just do it
here is what we'll do
now I'll just do it here I was going to
I was going to make it inside a full
loop but I thought why bother
I'll just have it's beautifully aligned
- so this kind of enforces shaders to
support textures I guess it doesn't
really if he doesn't find the uniform it
won't post it but there you go
all right setting all of our stuff here
30 - yes that's great and then that's it
and it's called Texas so let's just
build this and so why is this awesome
oh wait wow yeah that's right wait
weren't we enabling it yeah we are going
everything out there okay so now it
should totally work apart from the
pointer
yeah so you can see now the textures are
working correctly cool there you go guys
it's just as simple as that we're pretty
much complete so yes we get rid of this
because that will actually break code
but um so can we can we satisfy its
position easily not right now right
I mean renderable probably has not
doesn't yeah we could make it so that we
let's let's quickly expose our force
prior the same way that we did with
label so if you remember what we did
with label it we made a reference up
here it was public called position so
that's what I want to do with this as
well I'm going to if at renderable
should robably just have that but I'll
just add a force pry it manually so
position oh say it's M position right
and this is just handy because you'll
see why in a map and because we want to
control sprites positions pretty easily
anyway without any kind of function
calls or it'll implant it but this is
just better so what we'll do is we'll
make an up oh we need to make sure that
we're doing the right amounts of updates
per second because my timer we don't
know if that works so let's try updates
per second and that should be 60 59 60
61 that range
what now we must be returning the wrong
value yes we're changing frames per
second take two come on timer
yes okay good so that's good time is
happening that many times per second
change that back there and we'll also
print out
that as well let's override update and
we will say so right now this pride is
kind of in here
and then we'll say if window is keep
rest gel wk up then sprite dot position
dot y + + o that's what we have event
fast
and we made a little game pretty amazing
I mean it's part of a graphics test and
a game but you guys get the point I went
on demoing stuff like audio but whatever
oops
another that's - that's plus so let's
say
look at that alright doesn't work what
lulz my bad yeah check that out pretty
cool oh and I probably should not be L
sippin those things Eliza can only move
in two directions I'll rather in one
direction not diagonally there we go
pretty amazing and you can see how easy
it was to make that game it's this so
I'm going to end it there I hope you
guys enjoyed that let's quickly make a
or the last thing I wanted to do I
promise last thing I want to do was I
just said this live position we could do
that and update so window is that and
shader is that we didn't make a shade of
up here which probably have a layer I'll
get shatter as well but whatever
so yeah I'm actually quite happy with
how full this works pretty good um yes
such a beautiful coat um this winter
visit it up that's fine
okay and now if we go to basic and weary
enable this will find that we're all
good you can see there we go
you can move around and whatnot and you
can shine the light and we got my work
off inputs working and everything seems
to be going pretty well so anyway I hope
you guys enjoyed this episode there was
one thing I did this is a nitpick bit
and see how I print 0 first for the
first tick that's because the data
hasn't been populated yet we can fix
that by going into gas Sparky and just
popping this tick over here
you can say now it works because it will
take after it's got that data which is
good all right any questions leave them
below
as you can see spark is pretty much a
fully functional game engine or basic
one but it works and I yeah next episode
will be M scripting so that's going to
be fun and I'll see you guys next time
and if you enjoyed place the like button
goodbye
you